Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
game chess.
Checking in on you late Wednesday night
while my daughter sleeps in the next F
and Ruma. Yeah, I got to keep quiet
on this one. I got to keep it down.
Keep it down. I turned up the volume so
I can whisper a little bit here. Right.
I gotta knock this fucker up.
I got a table read for
episode eight of Season Three,
eight of 10 where 80% of the way
there for you mathletes out there.
Very excited.
Starting to see the light at the end of
the tunnel before the horrific editing
process begins. And uh, you know,
we'll just be working
for another year and uh,
get everything all locked and I'll have
maybe three days off and then we'll
start all over again. Bump
pump, pump, pump, pump, pump,
pump, pump, pump, pump. Oh,
Badu Ludo too. Um, what's going on? How
are you? I, yeah, how's your week going?
Is that all right?
I'm actually a have to do the table read.
I'm going to bright some more shit.
And then late night I'm going to be
traveling up to Toronto where I'm doing
three shows at the Sony
fucking sat up Toronto,
one of my favorite cities. You know, I
like, I like a nice small city, you know,
everybody knows everybody's name.
That's what I love about Toronto.
You know what I mean? It's not this
fucking monstrosity with a ton of traffic.
Everybody's done the earth now.
I actually really like, you know,
it's the biggest God damn city,
you know, basically for, uh,
people in the United States.
All right.
Who never look up when they're walking
around so they never see Canada. Right.
They dumb like me. Where north to you
is looking up cause you can't fucking,
you have no spatial relation to
how you stand on this planet. Um,
auto was the capital of Canada,
but Toronto is, is like,
it's kind of like how Albany is
like the capital of New York,
but it's all about New York City.
Albany is the capital of New York state,
I should say, and share.
They have the egg, you know,
they have a fucking
minor league hockey team.
There's a lot to like an Albany
got some beautiful theaters.
You know what I mean?
They got that fucking,
we used to build shit here before
it all left, you know, for 30 years.
And now we're coming back around
with a little tech savvy horse shit,
like all these fucking rust belt cities.
Not Saying Albany was in the rust belt,
but all I can look at,
look at what's going on in Pittsburgh.
The revitalization of the downtown area
is all these fucking nerds who make
websites and uh,
robots and you know,
synthetic heroin,
whatever the fuck it is these
nerds do for these sociopath's,
for these fucking sociopath.
That's how it works. Nerds,
I've said that my act nerds make
fucking sociopath dreams come true.
That's what the fuck they
do. Okay. Sociopath's are
crazy enough to think shit,
but they need a nerd to actually make
it a fucking reality in nerds do none of
the background to backbone,
I should say.
They don't have the backbone to tell
fucking sociopath's. You know what dude,
I know I, I could figure out how to do
that, but I'm not going to make that.
They won't do it.
And they're all sitting around making
robots that they can fuck right now to get
rid of that guilt.
Okay.
And we're taking collars were
taking callers will read them live.
Um, Toronto. What of Doing
Toronto? Toronto. Sorry.
Just had some fucking corn
checks. Um, by the way,
I haven't been working out cause
my cap was fucked up and I'm,
I'm still dropping weight just by not
boozing and eating like a fucking angel.
Do you know what I have
every fucking night?
Like probably four out of seven nights
a week at this premade to bully salad
that has this little,
I don't know if it's cous cous I
don't know what the fuck it is.
Tomatoes and onions in it.
And then I put a little fucking chicken
in there and I just eat that shit.
Like the fuel that it is,
I just shovel it into my mouth
to stop the, the hunger feeling.
And it's around five 36 and
then I owed do anything.
And if I get a little extra hug,
did a set tonight, you know,
burned a little calories.
Every once in a while I'll come home.
I just have a fucking bullet cereal and
then that's it. And I have to tell you,
dude, I gotta tell you,
I've got on the scale today,
all fucking Billy alabaster,
freckled fat tits was down to 175 pounds.
I was up to a buck 85 I
was a buck 90 last summer,
so I'm down to one 75 my fighting weight
is one 72 I got this acting Gig in two
fucking weeks and I've been unable to
work out my fucking rotator cuff is all
fucked up again.
I was imitating this blowup doll on stage
and I stuck my fucking arm out and it
started burning again. It's like, really?
Yeah,
I'm a chef, I'm a God damn man. I
have to, you know what I have to do?
I have to go to a physical
therapist and I have to,
I have to start being a better
patient. Like, you know,
when they tell me to do some shit,
I need to go fucking do the shit.
That's what the fuck I need to
do to finally get past the shit.
Cause I haven't worked out. You
know, I used to be pull up guy.
I got a bet with Paul Versey
that when I'm 70 years old,
I'm still be able to do 10 pull ups.
I want you to be able to do that.
When I turned 50 the way this is fucking
going on. What I'm trying to say here,
people is I'm falling apart. I know
there's a lot of benefits out there. Okay?
From, you know, people's
who's fucking, you know,
heads were fused together with their
brother would have whatever your fucking
causes.
All right.
What about broken down middle aged,
white male heterosexuals.
What about that? What do
all about? All of us. Okay.
After half a century of privilege,
you know,
what about us with our sore calf and our
soil, right shoulder. What about that?
How people,
you know,
I want to know how much you care.
Um,
I just want to turn a fucking corner
with this goddamn thing. You can't do it.
I haven't been able to do whatever
the other rotated cuffs at the tough,
you know, they gay kind of fucking linger.
I know, I know. I'm living with it. Um,
so my name is, I've been talking to
some people recently and you know,
I've always just joked around
about pharmaceutical companies.
I keep hearing this rumor
that they started the of
this fucking heroin epidemic
and everything. And I
just found out, you know,
someone from like the town I grew up
in 23 years old just fucking died of a
heroin overdose.
I grew up in fucking Mayberry and uh,
someone was talking about basically
all these fucking things, oxy,
Percocet, all of that shit. It has the
exact same fucking addictive qualities,
chemical makeup,
all of that shit is heroin.
It's just like a synthetic heroin and
a difference between an opiate and an
opioid.
And opiate is natural.
Like those poppy fucking things you
always see in those chuck Norris movies.
Right?
And then now the poppy seeds there
and then in a opiate is just like
manufactured nerds.
Nerds,
you fucking go to the doctor like me. I
fucked up my calf. This fucking guy goes,
all right, I'm going to give
you a painkiller and I'm
going to give you an anti
inflammatory.
So I go to the fucking pharmaceutical.
Pharmacists are fucking hilarious.
The fact that they get to dress up like
their doctors is one of the funniest
fucking things. It's like,
what are you doing in there?
It's like you're basically working
the Starbucks of the medical field.
You know what? What do you do?
What the fuck you do it back?
You should get me a cup of
coffee with my fucking pills.
They always act like they're so God damn,
you know,
just under the gun when you're back there,
you're counting aspirin.
I get, you know what? Enough way.
You know what the fucking worst
thing is is when somebody like,
it's like running. There's
nothing. People think cops are bad.
The worst thing you want to have fucking
attitude. Get a rent a cop. Cars in the,
in the,
in the back of his head.
He knows he's not a real cops and now
he's got something to prove. A cop's cop,
you know what I mean? Say He's, he
knows he's, you know, he's got a gun,
he's got a fucking license to kill him.
I'll stick this right in the back of
your fucking mouth and I'll pull the
trigger and go down and go to a sandwich
and I even think about it. Right?
Fuck around cup.
Where does he get maybe as a taser,
it got a little fucking stick.
So he's gotta be some cut and run
around taking some little fucking kid's
skateboard away, right? They, they,
they, they dabble in that shit.
So always that type of shit,
you know what I mean?
It's like if you're going
to get a threesome, right,
there's always the beautiful girl and
then the other one is fucking annoying.
Who's got to start running a Yap.
Even if she is beautiful,
she knows she's not as good
looking as the other one.
That brings up the insecurity and
then she won't shut the fuck up.
She tries to be funny or something like
that is stupid, sloppy tits hanging out.
It's like,
what are you doing?
I don't care how fucking ugly you are.
You don't think I'm gonna work my way
through you to get to her to shut up.
I don't know what the fuck this has to
do with pharmaceutical companies. Okay.
But I know when I went to this
pharmacy with my calf problem,
all right, I was supposed to get, he
said a painkiller. I'm like, well,
I'm not fucking with those.
I'm not getting heroin in a
fucking synthetic form and
start tailoring and look
how I handle beaus people,
or I should say,
look how Booz handled me.
Okay.
Who's like triple g walking
down Alvarez the other day.
That's what fucking booze does to me.
A backing up the whole fucking fight.
Maybe once a while I plant and I
fucking throw a cup of combinations.
You know what the bottle does? It
eats it up. Hey eats, sit upright.
But my wife's sitting there, gone here,
not an alcoholic has me winning one 18,
one 10. Figure that one
out. So I fucking go in
to a cvs. Right. Which is a great place.
If you need to buy somebody a card,
you know, get a gallon of root beer
and get some fucking heroin. Right.
Maybe some shit and fucking, I don't know,
shaving cream or some shit. Right? So
the fucking, you know, rent a fucking
Dr. Guy behind there. He fucking,
you know, it's, you know, it's
going to be like 20 minutes.
So I was gonna be like 20 minutes. All
right. Okay. Whatever. I get it. Yeah.
There's a lot of different
colored pills back there.
You got to look at your pill chart. See
which color the blue ones are for boys.
And the red ones are for old people,
whatever that sciences.
Okay.
They're, they're back. They're
acting like they make the pills.
I need to shut the fuck
up about pharmacists.
I got to read up on him here far months.
Let me finish selling the story. Um,
so the guy finally comes back,
right.
I'm standing by in all these cute
fucking old people, you know what I mean?
Fucking people with all that God damn
pills for the ailments and shit. Um,
and uh, he gives me two vials and I
go, okay, what's this one? He goes,
those are the pain pills, painkillers.
And I'm like, all right, well,
I'm not messing with that.
And I, and I go, what are
these? And he goes, those, uh,
those are more pain pills. And I'm like,
well, what about the anti inflammatory?
He goes, oh, it's, it's in these
painkillers. And it's just like,
oh, I don't want that. I just want the
antiinflammatory. But you know what it is,
is he's fucking drug companies.
They're drug dealers. So they get,
they want to get me hooked.
So you want the antiinflammatory,
you've got to do a little fucking
synthetic heroin one with it. Okay.
Now base in all of this on
my own fucking paranoia,
in like two conversations I've
had over the last 48 hours. Okay?
And now I'm in my fucking house,
like in that movie, Beautiful Mind.
I'm taking fucking,
I'm cutting out headlines from papers
that I don't read and upon on Blinken and
all together and I'm presenting
it as fact to you. Okay.
Pharmacists,
what do they do?
All right.
They advise physicians and other
health practitioners on the selections,
dosage interactions and
side effects of medication.
They also plan and monitor drug
programs or regimens. Pharmacists,
council,
hospitalized patients on the use of
drugs and on their use at home when the
patients are discharged. Yeah, you
made it the back of the CVS. Okay.
Take two of these twice a day.
Take one on the third day and
then flush the rest of it, right?
MMM.
Pharmacists
level of edgy to everything just
pops up like I wrote what and then it
immediately popped up.
Do they do,
I said level and immediately of
education immediately popped up.
Doctoral or professional degree.
All right.
Here's what you got to do.
There's no way this is, no, no.
This can't be more than a two year
fucking program. Okay. Here you go.
Here's a video on how to
be a fucking pharmacist.
It's a fucking cartoon character
in a pharmacist and a pharmacy.
Education requirements and career center.
Becoming a pharmacist requires a
significant amount of formal education.
Get the fuck Outta here. Learn
about education, job duties,
and trained to see if this is
the right career for you. Okay.
Find the perfect school k doctor
of pharmacy degree fields.
Non-Specified two years
of undergraduate study.
I got four is required to
apply for pharmacy school.
Okay.
License required in all states.
I got one of those to sell health
insurance. That's not impressive.
You take a test and then your licensed
experienced clerkship residency's
fellowships. This is bullshit.
Key skills, attention to detail.
Oh,
did I say for Percocet?
I met one a and an extensive
knowledge of drugs and interactions.
Okay, there you go. I'll give you
that one. Research, communication,
interpersonal and customer service skills.
Job Outlook.
3% growth.
Medium annual salary.
$121,500 given up for the
pharmacist. Jesus. No.
One of their lab coats is
so damn clean, Huh? Back.
They're raking in the fucking money.
I'll tell you if you start selling
some of those drugs on this side to the
people that you get
addictive in the front. Okay.
Yeah.
Do you know, I'm just saying you
get those fake tits. They're sweet.
[inaudible] um, I had an
amazing week this week.
I actually got to a,
I got to fucking play drums for about
two and a half hours with a tremendous
musician who is just like, hey man, do
you want to fucking jam? And I was like,
yeah man, I want to jam. And I
didn't even know what that meant.
I thought it was going to go down there
and just be like, hey, you do, you know,
highway to hell. That's what I thought
it was going to be. I showed up,
this guy was doing that yellow
have Reggie watts thing where yeah,
we fucking builds up,
he'll make like drum sounds and then
I'll make guitar songs and then whatever
and whatever, whatever. And then he
starts fucking singing over it. Right. Um,
he was doing that but with like a guitar
and he was just creating these songs.
And then I had to jump in and play drums
and it was just a whole other fucking
animal. And I realized that all these
years I thought that I played drums.
I didn't, I like do drums. I was talking
about somebody who bought that today.
I like do drums. I don't play
them. You know what I mean?
Playing him is what I attempted to do
the other night and failed horrifically.
See if you fucking listen to a song and
you listen to what the drummer's doing,
you figure it out,
then you play it.
That's like getting all the answers to
the test and then the drum part fits,
fix fits because the other guy
already came up with it. But you,
somebody just starts playing you a
piece of music he never heard of.
And then you have to actually come
up with the drum part. You are, um,
the level of musician that you are as
immediately exposed and there's nowhere
for you to hide.
And I was just, I, we had a great time.
I had such a fucking fun time doing it,
but I was actually thinking, I was
like, wow man. I knew I sucked.
I didn't know I sucked. Wow. Um,
but it was a, it was so much
fun and the person was really,
really generous and I want
to thank him for a fucking
okay.
Hang on that long with me. But it was
such a fun fucking time and it was also,
you know, it was a very huge learning. So
it wasn't, you know, it was a few moments.
I actually thought I played pretty good.
But other than that I was just like,
Jesus Christ just kept trying
to do stuff and then, you know,
you just make that face.
Like I'm not bad at that too.
I don't know if you professional drummers
can try and fill and you don't you
fuck up, you know, do you make
a face? Cause I always do.
I make that,
oops,
you don't have face John Paul Jones made
when him and bought him fucked up in a
song remains the same.
They came in a little too early.
But John Paul Jones says back to the
crowd and you see bon and looked down and
he just kind of shakes his head for half
a second and then they got it right.
Um,
I dunno what I'm talking about.
I'm just trying to fill up this fucking
half hour cause I have no fucking time.
I have no time in my life anymore. You
know what I mean? I don't, I need to,
I need a pharmacist in my fucking
life. You know what, you know,
I don't take pills aside from the fact
that I don't want to get addicted is, uh,
what I like about drinking is I enjoy
the effort it takes to get the buzz.
You know what I mean? Like I don't
like, uh, like we just seem so easy,
especially now with all these fucking
vaporizers and stuff. I'll eat you inhale,
you're doing that anyways. Then you
just sit there and all say, hey man,
blah blah blah, but fucking
drinking. You gotta drink it.
Yeah.
If you're going to get shit
faced just drinking beer,
that's a lot of Goddamn work.
You've got dre,
he drink at least six of them feel
lightweight, upwards of fucking, you know,
I dunno, 36 to 40 depending
on, how bout you Drake.
So anyways, look at this shit. So
I went to this um, this website
and it was like, what is the
difference between heroin and Percocet?
And this is like fucking nuts.
This is like people who were like on these
drugs talking in this, this chat room.
Like what is the difference?
Someone told me I should buy some
versus buying 30 milligrams of oxycodone
because it should be a lot cheaper.
So what are your opinions?
Somebody taught, basically told this
person who is addicted to these,
this fucking oxy, they should
now get heroin. So this guy
just, this is such like,
like they talking about cars or some shit.
This person says,
well they are both strong narcotics.
Heroin is an opiate and
oxycodone is an opiod,
which is basically in layman terms,
opioids are synthetics and
opiates occur naturally.
And the opium poppy, in my
opinion, heroin is stronger.
But then that's countered by the fact
that you'll never know street heroins
purity. And you always know what's
in an oxy, am I saying that right?
Oxy coating tablet, do you buy 30
milligrams of 30 milligram tablets?
You know how strong it is.
Heroin purity can go up and down and
they cut it with all kinds of shit.
These are fucking people doing hard drugs.
First of all,
I got to give it up that they could
still fucking have the sense to go into a
chat room
and compare fucking notes.
So
does a lot of people talking about this,
but not in,
not on CNN,
on Fox News or any of those other fucking
so-called news channels where they're
all bought and paid for and they're not
going to do this fucking story because
you know,
the same companies that get everybody
allegedly got everybody addicted or
advertising on their fucking channels.
Um,
so Ohio is suing drug companies over
their role in creating an opioid epidemic,
which has led to an opiate epidemic.
Uh,
cause after a while they won't
fill you fuck a prescription.
So NPRs Robert Siegel talks
with Ohio attorney general.
Did you get to the bullshit here?
The state of Ohio figures?
It's home to 200,000 opiod addicts.
That's the equivalent.
The population of Akron
overdoses are so common.
The morgues in some Ohio
counties lack for space.
Today's Ohio, uh, today,
Ohio's attorney general announced
he's bringing a suit against five drug
manufacturers accusing them
of misrepresenting the risk
of prescription opioids
and helping to fuel an addiction
epidemic in this state. Yeah.
Like these people are like murdering
people. If what they're saying is true,
that's what the fuck they're doing in
these fucking cunts. These corporate cons,
they go to bed fucking silk,
pajamas,
indoor and outdoor pool is
everybody's fucking dying.
I don't know the uh,
population control person in me sorta
like I'm on both sides of this thing.
It's like this is fucking terrible that
do to people. Then it's also like, well,
there's 20 people on the planet,
so thank God these fucking psychos are
killing people so they can get a bigger
house. I heard the like, you know,
any doctors listen to this shit
anonymously want to write in.
I mean I heard like they have like
these pharmaceutical companies see,
hire these hot chicks to walk around to
bring in the new drugs wearing like fuck
me pumps and stuff.
Is that true or did it was I have asleep
sleep watching some red shoe diary one
night. I thought it was in
this industry. I have no idea.
So the State Attorney General Mike,
the win or,
or d wine is he known as he's known
around the way joins us now from Columbus.
Welcome to the program. Once
again, I'll fuck this is the, uh,
somebody who the fuck would read this
is this for like deaf people who can't
hear NPR.
Mike [inaudible] good to be back.
Thank you very much Segal.
And first tell us which companies
have you named in the suit.
We have sued the following companies,
Purdue Pharma,
endo health solutions,
Janssen or Yansen pharmaceuticals,
cephalon and then Allergan.
Okay.
Why the fuck? Why wouldn't
you just summarize all of
this? I guess I can hit play.
It's a five minute interview.
I don't have time for that shit.
US officials are starting to treat
opiod companies like big tobacco.
About time and how the city
is suing pharmaceutical.
Don't vilify drug companies says cvs.
Really?
Oh Jesus. He's how button
paid for these fuckers? Well,
but you don't mind when I
hear their opinion first.
Only America would vilify the people that
invented Viagra. That's what happened.
That's what's happening.
Parentheses sort of.
They just bought back everything they
just said this week is the FDA holds very
public hearings and the potential health
risks of popular prescription pain
medication such as Cox,
two inhibitors,
Pfizer, the company that
makes one of those medicines.
Celebrex is also the company that
brought you in yours. Viagra,
drug companies,
big farmers.
The villains of medicine and health
care at least according to much media.
Who the fuck wrote this horseshit.
This is by,
I swear to God.
Booty cost grove Mather.
All right.
I don't understand how you can be anywhere
in journalism with a first name booty.
All right. Have I, have I made enough of
an ass of myself talking about this shit?
Um, you know I love about this country
is whores can give press conferences.
All right, let's do some. Um, all right,
let me do a little advertising here.
Oh, look who's back. Indochina.
Indochino uh,
talk about how every man looks
better in a suit. Listen,
I've always been attracted to men,
but nothing gets my loins going.
Like seeing another man
walked by in a suit.
Something about hearing those slacks
rubbing together in Doe China.
China is making it easy to get a perfectly
tailored suit at an incredible price.
You can choose from hundreds of top
quality fabrics and personalize your suit
just the way you want it.
Whether it works,
whether it's for work or a wedding
or another special occasion,
okay?
It's going to work is
not a special occasion.
That's what the fuck he up to
a wedding special occasion.
Where are you going, honey, to a special
occasion. All I'm going to work. Well,
what the fuck is it?
He's going to work.
Indochino has suited up hundreds of
thousands of men and and now the largest
made to measure men's brand,
men's wear brand in the world.
Here's how it works.
Does it a showroom or stop
online@indochino.com pick your fabric.
Pick your poison.
Choose your customizations from lapels
to pleats to jacket linings and more.
What the fuck else is their shoulders?
Submit your measurements.
Place your order and wait for it to
arrive at just a few weeks. Yeah,
robot shows up wearing your jacket.
Fucking choke shout this week.
My listeners can get any premium
Indochino suit for just 379 bucks it
indochino.com when entering bird checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for
a made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com Promo Code Burger
for any premium suit for just three to
$79 and free shipping.
It's incredible deal for a suit that
will fit you better than anything off the
rack ever could. All right. Oh,
look who's here. Look who's here.
It's sold zip.
Are you hiring well? Are you?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Talk about the challenge of finding you.
Fuck you.
You talk about it with Ziprecruiter.
You can post your job to 100 plus
job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful
technology efficiently,
the right people to your job better
than anyone else. That is why zip
is different.
Unlike other job sites,
ZipRecruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you. It finds them
all right? It's like that guy chasing
fucking the guy crashed a plane,
Hans Solo. You know? Remember that guy,
the guy from no country for old men,
he's going to find you. Tommy Lee
Jones, Harrison Ford, Bam, Bam.
It's in fact 80% of employees
who post a job on zip a credit,
get a quality candidate through
this site within just one day.
No juggling fucking emails
or calls to your office.
You don't have time for that shit.
You got to hit the golf course.
Simply screen rate and manage
candidates all in one place with zip.
Easy to use dashboard.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been
used by businesses of all sizes to find
the most quality job qualified job
candidates with immediate results.
And right now my listeners can
post jobs on Ziprecruiter for free.
That's right free. Just go to
ziprecruiter.com/bird that's right.
ziprecruiter.com/per one more time.
Got It for free at Zip.
Okay.
Slipper. All right. Oh, look
who's here. All right, everybody.
You weren't taught all week.
You were tired all week.
Why not fucking take your paycheck
and throw it on some football games?
Draft kings,
everybody.
Football season has begun and it's not
too late to take your paycheck sticking
on the table and never
fucking see it again.
Or you get closer to the game
you love with draft kings.
One week fantasy football.
This Sunday ran kings is hosting
and $100,000 pick 'em contest.
That is totally fucking fried.
Enter pickup is the newest way to
play one week fantasy football.
The one night stand of sports gambling.
Draft your team.
Drafting your team is faster than ever.
Draft Kings has organized
players into eight tiers.
All you have to do according to what?
Skin color.
How are you doing this?
All you have to do is select.
Are there eight different skin colors?
Well, if you get into shades are,
if you just like a racist person,
there's like black, white, Asian,
native American.
Yeah,
Italian. Not don't what
the fuck. Oh, serious.
Choose between public contest with big
cash prizes or private contests where you
can compete against a
group of your friends.
Draftkings also has beginner in casual
contest or you can play against people of
the same similar skill level.
Everybody gets a trophy.
The best part is you get to
draft a new team each week,
week without any commitment. So get you
know, and if your team shits the bed,
you don't have to pack up and leave town
like Pete Carroll when he ran out the
back door.
Uh,
so get the draft kings.com now and use
Promo Code Burr to play in draftkings
free contest with $100,000
in total prices this Sunday.
Use My Promo Code Burr to
play for free this Sunday.
This that's Promo Code [inaudible] at
draftkings.com eligibility restrictions
apply. See draftkings.com
for details. All right,
the last fucking read.
This is the last fucking read
that I have to do. Oh my God,
that was a little Don Henley.
Remember Don and he put out that great
fucking album, the late eighties.
What a songwriter. What a showman. A lift.
Everybody.
Lyft knows that drivers
are what keeps them moving.
So they do everything they can to make
sure their drivers are happy on every
trip.
Lift believes that being a ride sharing
driver should be fun if you're having a
good time.
Also the passengers,
if you're choosing a ride
sharing company to drive for,
go with the company that treats
you better. It's lift now.
Like those slave driving
bastards over at Uw, at Uber,
you want to go with Lyft,
you get tips at this fucking place.
The only tips you get it over is, hey,
here's a tip. You ain't make it shittier.
So shut the fuck up and keep
driving. That's how they
treat him over there, right?
Lyft is the North Sea.
I mean,
Uber is the North Korea
of ride sharing apps.
Uh, live was the first
to offer in APP tipping.
Can imagine a few are fucking Lyft
driver and you picked up Kim Jong Il,
or maybe just somebody who look like,
you know what I mean? You're like, well,
he wouldn't be over here.
He doesn't like us.
Maybe that's just some fat Asian kid who
likes to have a Hitler youth haircut.
I don't know where you go.
And serve
to the airport. Live was the
first offer. Inept tipping.
When you drive for Lyft,
you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers have been paid over $200
million in tips since the feature was
introduced. Express pay lets
drivers get paid almost instantly.
Instead of waiting for weeks,
you can earn hundreds of dollars a
week plus tips. One, earn more money,
drive more. It's never been
easier to give yourself a raise.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers means happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft
rides get a perfect five star rating the
others and in a fiery crash.
So join the ride sharing company
that believes in treating people,
treating its people better.
Go to lift.com/bird today and you
can get a $500 new driver bonus.
That's right. lyft.com/ [inaudible]
it's a limited time only.
L Y F t.com/. Bar. That's it.
Fuck you. I'll talk to
you later. Um, honestly,
32 minutes. Okay. People I want you
guys all have a wonderful weekend.
I want you to get on your knees and
give thanks that you don't live in the
Caribbean with all them tornadoes coming.
Why don't we say tornadoes,
hurricanes coming,
uh,
everybody in Puerto Rico, I
help you make it out. All right?
I just saw was coming yesterday, man. It's
fucking brutal, man. It's really brutal.
The same way they are going after these
pharmaceutical companies for a, the,
you know, the opioids,
opiates, ob and cheese,
the Endo Chinos,
right?
They should go after fucking fossil
fuel companies at some point.
That's going to fucking happen,
you know?
But she can never get the
people that made the decision.
Because what you're doing is you're,
you're suing a corporation,
which is nameless and faceless.
And then all those people who made those
fucking decisions collectively turn
your key. They all turned their
fucking key. I was following orders.
All of those fucking cuts when you go to
sue the company or completely insulated
and they will be giving themselves
raises with their blood money.
And then when they go to
fucking attack the company,
everybody just fucking walks
away. It's like, well, I work
there. I am not, you know,
I'm not the corporation.
Okay.
Yeah. Why are you still talking? I'm
sorry. I gotta go to fucking bed. Alright.
Anyways, don't be a con
this weekend everybody. Huh?
And don't watch the fucking news. All it's
gonna do is make you feel fucking set.
Go out. Be a good person.
You know, somebody asks you
to get in their trunk. Just,
you know, just don't do it.
That's all I'm saying. All right?
Does that make any sense? I
don't give a fuck. All right. Um,
please enjoy this music as we a,
you're going to get another half hour of
fucking riveting entertainment like the
last fucking 33 minutes of this shit
show from a Thursday afternoon podcast
that's gone by you a Thursday from another
year or possibly earlier this month.
All right?
I'll see all you people in Toronto.
I can't wait to go up there and give
you my brand new IRA fucking bullshit.
I'll be there with Paul Versey.
That dude, I called a kid the pride,
a New Jersey,
you know,
someday Paul Verges going to walk through
the pearly gates wearing a brand new
pair of Jordan threes.
He's fucking dope.
Did Jordan trees with my,
so in those wingstone over all right.
Have a great weekend.
I've got,
see what's on the camera.
I'm just being vs today.
Ah,
I'm just
[inaudible]
you go
all right. X Defense Minister from
Canada speaks out about, speaks, uh,
speaks about, see that is what
not, once again, not my fault,
this person writes x defense.
Mez.
Minister from Canada speaks
about out about aliens,
out about aliens or speaks out about
aliens or does he speak about out about
aliens? See what I'm saying?
This isn't always me.
Alright, Bill loved the podcast,
freelance every week. Uh,
they're much appreciated,
Yada, Yada, Yada.
I thought you might like this link
as you're a big conspiracy theory,
a big conspiracy theorist.
You mean?
He said it's the former
Canadian defense administrator.
No Canadian defense minister giving some
bold claims about several species of
aliens living among us and actually
working with elements in the government.
Uh, not only that, but a shadowy cabal.
C A, B, a, l, k, but k bow, I dunno,
comprised of the council on foreign
relations, the build the Burgers,
the
trilateral commission.
That should add a hyphen in it. You
caught the international banking cartel.
Uh,
the oil cartels,
members of various intelligent organizes
the select members and military Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
One world government. Check it out, sir.
The last thing I'm going to do is look
at this. I'll put the link up there. Ah,
fuck it.
I'll look at it right now.
This shit just freaks me out and makes
me depressed because there's nothing I
could do about it. Okay. Now, how
is this going to help me, sir?
If I find out there's actually
aliens living among us,
talking to international bankers,
you know, am I gonna come walking in,
bursting into their meeting like
the end of a feel good movie?
Yeah.
You know, like, hey man, the people
have spoken and they like me.
All right, here we go.
I got it right here. Uh,
Canada's former minister
of national defense,
Paul Haler testifies at the
citizens hearing on disclosure,
where the fuck am I last
month in Washington DC that
aliens are living among us
and that it is likely at least two of
them are working with the u s government.
Oh, this guy sounds like he's out
of his fucking mind. Ah, let, let's,
let's, let's, let's kind of flip the
script here. Let's say you're an alien.
All right.
Whoever's listening to this still,
who believes in aliens who was in blogging
about my reaction to the blogger? Um,
can you go to ego to another
fucking solar system now the galaxy,
whatever the fucking terminology is,
and you land there,
okay,
what are you going to do other
than try and get blended it.
Blend in so people don't chop
your fucking alien head off.
Like how exactly did
this fucking alien get?
Infiltrate the government.
This is like Mr. Smith goes to Washington.
The alien just lands and just goes,
okay. Ah, right. I mean, how come
he didn't do this in Argentina?
He picks the United States,
goes right into fucking Washington DC
walks into the Capitol building and
somebody filibustering so they can't
make an electric car or whatever comes
right out on the house
floor and then does what,
you know,
security comes up,
tries to shoot him and he just puts his
hands up and their guns turned into like
chocolate bars or fall to the ground and
then for some reason everybody in their
suits doesn't scramble
and freak the fuck out,
you know?
No,
you just fucking walk out there and say,
hey, what's going on? Relax, relax, relax.
It's a simple technology
that you guys will discover.
If you become friends with me,
hired attorney could fucking gone into
some melted shit that doesn't let people
shoot you. I am from the
planet. Zol Tar. Right.
It always begins with z.
How does that work?
Like if you were a fucking alien and
you went to another God damn plan it.
Exactly, I guess. Okay.
You'd be like, all right,
if there's a bunch of different nations,
which one seems to be running? Shit.
I got to chop the head off and you're
just going to want you and you and a buddy
till you
gonna walk in fucking arm and arm
and do what? Yeah. Hey, listen. Uh,
I think just the simple fact that worry
we were able to get here. You know,
the kind of firepower
that we're capable of. Um,
for some fucking reason we want to take
over this planet or we want you guys to
do shit the way we feel
that the it should be done.
Who? Who would want that
fucking headache? I don't,
I don't know that I believe this shit.
Anyways,
he believes Hellyer whose beliefs are
extra life, extra terrestrial life.
And you are so your foes
are well established.
Made the statements at the nongovernmental
hearings chaired by six former US
congressman and aimed at
according to the events website,
doing what the u s congress
had failed to do for 45 years.
Seek out the facts surrounding the most
important issue of this or any other
time. Evidence pouring towards
an extraterrestrial presence,
engaging the human race.
All right. You know what,
even I have my limits when it comes
to that type of shit. All right.
I don't think that's the most
pressing thing I would say. Yeah,
I was fucking up the environment, world
population and that type of suit. Shit,
it's a little more,
unless you want to throw more people
from other galaxies also living here too.
Do they drink bottle
water to
[inaudible]
you can't get
[inaudible].
Um, all right. Sisters
a through c. Here we go.
Uh,
tired of giving advice to guys with
psycho suicidal girlfriends or people with
STDs. Well, I got something
a bit lighter for you here.
A kind of like the cores lite version
of your typical advice. Thank you.
And is perfect for the middle of summer.
Like kick my feet back on this one.
So I know this
who I'd been friends with,
uh, for awhile now and banged one time.
She's the oldest of three sisters,
so we all call her sister a. About
two years ago I made out with sister,
be in a club, not my initiative, um,
and ended up having sex with there
the same night. Jesus Christ. Dude,
I went out with her.
Do,
do they have like that thing on the back
of their SUV where they had this stick
figures of the entire family and
you just slowly keep axing them out
and the family doesn't
understand if somebody's trying
to kill my daughters. No,
just trying to fuck all of them, sir.
Well, that's a relief. All right.
Um, anyways, I went out
with her for awhile. Oh,
this is sister B.
And it was surprisingly not awkward
when we were hanging out all together,
even though everyone knew the situation.
Jesus Christ,
what's southern state are you in sir? Um,
I'll go fuck yourself people down south.
That was funny. Um, some months later,
sister bea left me for one of her,
one of my friends and got
over it quickly enough. Oh,
got over it quickly enough.
And nowadays I'm still in contact with
sister a and B since I'm not the kind of
guy that holds a grudge for that
kind of stuff. Oh, there you go.
That's very mature,
which means you really didn't give
a fuck about either one of them.
So why are you going to be all upset?
You know,
like you own their pussy once you fuck
it. I hate when, I hate when guys do that.
Anyways,
recently senses to see,
started talking to me more
frequently after talking for a bit.
She said she could pose for me since
I'm a painter and she's a model and a 10
all the fucking way I might add.
Oh you fucking creep.
You fucking creep.
So she was attend the whole time.
So basically you're in a holding pattern
banging her oldest sisters waiting
until this girl was of age so he could
fucking painter Jesus Christ. I gotta I,
you know, I might have to
stand up and applaud this one.
This guy has taken it to another level.
This is a fucking epic situation
here. So you see, here's my question.
Does that proposition mean anything?
Do you need my advice?
I need advice from you. How do you
fuck every girl in the same family?
Jesus Christ. This is like, you know,
long there's been at, they'd spend,
since there's been a triple
crown winner in horse racing,
the last time someone
won the Kentucky Derby,
the Preakness and the breeders' Cup,
is that what it is or is that a
soccer match? I don't fucking know.
I don't own a fucking horse
since the late seventies.
I would guarantee that it's been since
the late seventies sent somebody has
booze. Bang three. I think a
lot can do two in one family,
but to get all fucking three, two, three,
two is a respectable three. Is it? No,
it's beyond respectful. Two. Three. Okay.
Everybody knows it's three is
in the sporting world. Do that.
That's a fucking dynasty. Okay.
You just put yourself in there.
We're fucking Bill Russell.
You put yourself in there
with, with, with the fucking,
uh, Magic Johnson Lakers. You know,
I wouldn't say the Colby Lakers.
You know when you go out and you get
Phil Jackson and fucking check, then it,
that's that new shit that the kids
like. I don't like that shit. Um,
either way, dude, you're
talking fucking dynasty. Wait,
magic never won three in a row,
but he had the Celtics to fuck with
named when three out of four years.
Give me a fucking break. Um, so
here's Michael Jordan. There we go.
So here's my question. Does that
proposition mean anything? Is it a trap?
Should I try to bang her?
Should I try and bang her too and get a
third strike or keep my dick in my pants
and avoid a potential
shitstorm and if yes,
do you have any tips,
special tips on this special situation?
All my friends are telling me to do so,
but I thought I'd ask them more refined
mine like yourselves before I did a move.
Dude, you are looking at me like,
dude, you're beyond me right now. Okay.
This is like Bull Durham. I'm, I'm fucking
Kevin Costner. Um, I'm, I'm a lifer.
Okay. You're, you're,
you're going up to the show.
Hit and brand new balls every fucking
day. I will. You tell me. Okay.
I never bank two girls in
one fucking family. You know,
I was psyched if I was able to tag a
couple of friends and we were all hanging
out at a bar one night and you get that
feeling like I fuck both of you and you
both knew it and you both loved it. I
hope. Please, please tell me you liked it.
Did you like it was I okay? Um, dude,
I think you gotta do it. You
got to do it. You know, you,
you've been above board the
whole time, sister. A sister be,
they all fucking knew
everything right now.
I understand this is a little delicate.
Okay.
He's trying to snip the last wire here.
This is the kid sister.
This is it going to blow up in your
fucking face. Uh, it's worth it, dude.
It's worth it. It's worth losing a couple
of limbs and your nose on this one.
You got to do it to fuck you. No, dude.
What the fuck she says to you? I,
yeah,
you're,
you're a painter all let me take my
clothes off and get paid my fucking Twat.
Let's not art too. That's foreplay. Give
me a fucking break. It'd be one thing.
If you're in a classroom of people, it's
just you and she's standing there naked,
dude,
that's like one of the TIF they ever done
that porn senate and that scenario in
a porn Jesus Christ,
you might've found a new angle
to. That's phenomenal. That is fucking
phenomenal, dude. You got to do it.
You got to do, what did John Elway
retired when he only got one?
He came back for another,
right?
You got to do it to
two.
That's like when Bush fucking
the first Bush, he stopped.
He didn't get to sit down. You got
to go all the way on this one, man.
All right?
You gotta be like Marlon Brando in fucking
apocalypse now. You just, you just,
you just accept the fact you
left the program. All right?
And
I don't care how mad
these girls get to do.
You are at the precipice of
becoming an absolute fucking legend.
Legend who, who can, who can, who's
gonna be able to top that dude?
There are celebrities who've had orgies,
they've had five on ones and
all that type of Shit, okay?
But I guarantee you they never fucked
three fucking girls in the same family
when they weren't famous,
not famous.
You're doing this shit with the gift of
Gab. Whatever the fuck you doing, dude,
you do this. You got to write a book.
You gotta write a book, that's fine.
You know that's easy to do.
Collection of the most amazing pussy
getting stories ever that you can somehow
confirm, all right, and it has
to be none of that bullshit.
The second you get famous, he get
money. That doesn't count. All right?
That's garbage time.
Okay?
They put the fucking second team in
there and you just fucking Titone layups.
That's bullshit. I'm talking
about just regular dude. You,
you talk yourself into it through. You're
a fucking legend. You got to do it.
All right. This might halftime
speech. I'm going to quote Joe Barton.
[inaudible] quoting John Madden today
is going to be the greatest day of your
life,
but only if you win.
All right?
You got to do it.
He got to fucking do it and keep it
[inaudible] the future.
[inaudible] he's told me,
hey,
what's going on?
This is bill burr and this is the
Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
September 21st, 2009. This is like the
fifth time I've tried to start this thing.
I don't know where to begin this week.
Uh,
I am psyched because I am in Los Angeles
at least for a today and tomorrow
before I fly right back out again.
I'm getting ready to do another special.
So I have to,
I'm in comedy bootcamp right now.
I did a Gig at Boston
University this weekend,
the weekend before I was in Philadelphia,
the weekend before I was in Stockholm,
Sweden. Let me think. I had
a week off and now I got it.
I got a four week intensive right here
where I just keep fucking going out and
uh, my, my act is going to get
really tight during this time.
But um, you ever see those fat people
on the biggest loser where they're like,
they're losing weight, but that look
of pain when they're on the treadmill?
That's what I have right now.
If the stand up comedy version of that,
you know,
where there's some,
a good looking woman who sort
of manly standing over me going,
you got to tell more jokes. Do you guys
watch your show? Biggest loser deck.
Did the girl on the woman,
the female,
the broad on that show is
like, I dunno, she's really,
really hot,
but she's really like manly.
And I wrote me and she looks like a mess.
She just moves.
There's like nothing dainty about her.
Actually.
Some girl you kind of play fight with
and then she just unleashed one into your
ribs and you'd be like,
okay,
you definitely had older brothers
because you know how to throw a punch.
Why are your eyebrows so big?
All right.
So if you're new to the podcast and I
can't figure out why this fucking thing
keeps red line in like that,
turn down the record level here.
Maybe that's the problem. Um,
if you new to this podcast,
I do one of these every God damn week.
I've been doing them for about two years
at this point and I pretty much, uh,
I don't think I've really
missed a week really. I mean,
occasionally I put them in on Tuesdays,
but generally speaking,
I don't miss a week. So they
come out every Monday and, uh,
people send me in questions,
they send me in their list of stuff
that they feel is underrated. Overrated.
We recommend some youtube videos
and websites. We interpret dreams.
No, actually we don't, you know what,
that was one that I always want,
I've been meaning to do.
Um,
people keep asking me for advice and
it keeps getting deeper and deeper and
deeper and um,
evidently haven't,
I've been getting some decent reviews
with my advice, but you got to understand,
you're talking to the guys pretty much
fucked up in every area of his life.
Like here's one. Oh yeah. Let me see if I
can find this one. Actually, the, how was,
I was on the plane and I was
going through the emails.
I'll,
I guess I'll have to paraphrase.
This guy basically sent me in one
that was asking advice
and he said that he was,
he was married to a Chinese woman
who was like seven years older than him.
They had a 10 year old kid
and he was from like Vietnam.
I don't fuck a remember, but all I
know is they got a kid and he's tired.
He's not attracted to her anymore.
And he wanted some advice and it's
just like to I, I, I don't know.
I mean that sounds about right.
You know,
you've been together for how long now?
Why would I say something like that? See,
that's why I don't wanna I don't want
to fucking talk about stuff that that's
got, that's, that's that fucking
deep, you know what I mean?
Yeah. I can see that.
I think that's normal.
Don't they call it like the
seven year rich, you know,
you're in a relationship
for like seven years or so,
or maybe 10 years and after
awhile it's like, you know,
when it comes to the physical thing,
it's like there's no room left in
your house where you haven't fucked.
There's no position that you haven't done.
You know,
mean my girls a pain in the ass.
She just walking out of the room,
threw her head back. Are you serious?
Are you seriously going to talk about
me this way? Because if you are,
I'm gonna storm out. Um, yeah.
I don't know what to tell you.
Why do you always do that? Nia,
you just stick your head in you.
You start looking at me like that's
gonna make me not be an asshole.
I'm always going to be an asshole.
Um, so anyways, this is what I,
this is what I did. This is why you
can't be here when I do these. Nia,
you have to leave. Close the
door. Be a good girl. Come on.
Come in here. All right, well what?
You're distracting me. Close the door. Oh,
that's a good girl. Ah, you're the
worst. You just keep walking in and out.
It's fucking brutal. 11,
12, 13 seconds wasted.
Oj. When your girl puts on
flip flops, that's the worse.
When they're being annoying and you
keep hearing the sound of that Sandal
hitting the fucking healer,
their foot.
And you need to be a little more
sensitive. And then that silence here
[inaudible] you're walking through some
horrific mall that you don't even want
to be in. Oh, look at those
sunglasses, those acute,
I want sunglasses. There
you go. There you go guys.
That's how you get rid of your girl.
Just start trashing what they're wearing
and then they store them up, you know?
And then I guarantee you six
hours from now she'll be like,
do you really not like when I wear
flip flops? I thought you like those.
Oh my God,
why didn't you say something?
I just feel so stupid right now.
You know the way she had an
argument about health, you know,
I know I can't stand about fucking women.
I just do this every week.
But it's annoying. It's frustrating. I
can't fucking stand the way they turn.
Little things,
nothing into these big fucking dramatic
Falcon Crest fucking moments where all
of a sudden like I'm
supposed to feel like, sorry,
I can't fucking stand that.
You know?
Like I was flying back yesterday. I
couldn't, you know, from the east coast,
I can't find my keys.
All right.
Now for those of you who listen
to my podcast all the time,
you know that I drive a hybrid like a fig.
I drive a Prius,
right? It's a great fucking
car. I totally recommend it.
Especially if you live in a city. Why
would you buy a sports car in a city? Huh?
You're going to be stuck in traffic.
The car's going to get all fucked up
cause you can't blow out the lines or
whatever the fuck you supposed
to do. Actually reality
is I can't afford the car.
I want it. So I'm just going to trash
people who can anyways, plumbing ahead.
So how it works with the Fancy Prius is
you don't have to stick your key in the
lock and you don't even have to press
a button. As long as it's on you.
The second you get in the vicinity of
the handle and you touch it, it unlocks.
Okay. Which you know is
supposed to be like, wow, wow.
We really are going to fucking have
flying saucer some days like moment.
You know? So evidently, but that,
that little mechanism that's supposed
to make my life so much easier.
If I lose that thing, it costs like
two or 300 bucks to get a new one.
And I can't just be like,
well,
why don't you just give me one
that has a fucking key on it?
Cause I don't think that that option
exists. Does it now? Maybe it does.
I don't fucking know.
So all I know is I thought I
lost like that two or $300 thing.
I hung around watching the Patriots jets,
the game went a little bit long cause
those country refs call the fucking
penalty every two seconds.
So now I was in jeopardy of missing
my flight and I can't find my keys.
So I'm rushing around the house. I tore
apart my luggage like twice. All right.
And then I call my girl up and she answers
the phone and I'm like, I'm like, Hey,
did I leave my keys out in la? They
only make, he's out in La. She goes, um,
yeah, yeah, you left him in the car. I
said, okay, cool. All right. I'll, uh,
no, no, no. She answered it right away. So
she goes, yeah, you left them in the car.
And I said, okay. Okay. All right,
cool. I'll call you from the airport.
And she just goes, okay. I just, yeah,
that you want attached to me
for a minute. You know, they,
they create that fucking moment.
You know what I mean?
That's why women are not in battle
in war. Right. Fucking there.
He'd start giving quick
fucking, you know, orders. Ah,
thank you.
Asking me how my day in the Fox Hall
went fires before he just started telling
me charge up the hill.
No, that's okay. You know,
I don't know. I don't, I don't tolerate
that. So when they say shit like that,
well I guess, I guess you too
busy to talk to me. That's right.
I am. All right. See you later. You know,
and then you just fucking go. Four, three,
two, one. And then the phone calls again.
What's the problem?
Is there a problem?
And then you're in it. You're in the
fucking fight that they wanted. A,
he just can't fucking actually
you can win, you can win.
You just going to live a lonely life,
but you can win. And speaking of that,
this is something I learned the other,
you know,
I use the word console out
here on my podcast and um,
I don't know how they
hell I came across this,
but I would like to read to you guys
about a street that existed in the Middle
Ages by the name of Grope cunt lane.
I'm not bullshitting
you grope current lane,
pronounced grope current
lane or they come late.
They have to have that like
I can't read English. Okay.
Was this street name found in English
towns and cities during the middle ages
believe to be a reference to the
prostitution centered on those? Uh,
in those areas it was normal
practice from an evil names,
street names to reflect the streets
function or economic activity taking place
within it. Grope. Cont
the earliest known use of,
which is about 1230 after the death of
that dude that everyone thought was holy,
um,
appears to have been derived as a
compound of the words grope and cunt.
Don't you hate when people explain
obvious shit? Like really? Yeah.
I couldn't put the two
of those grope content.
What are the w everyone
knows what groping is,
you know, there's no other word
for what else can grow up mean
and [inaudible] is yet.
Yeah, grub contact. Got It.
Why do I have puberty lately
on this? I got it, Ma.
I really like this girl in
class. What do I say? Um,
streets with that name.
We're often in the busiest parts
of medieval towns and cities. Yeah,
it's a red light district and at least
one appears to have been an important
thoroughfare. Um, although,
although the name was once
commonly common throughout England,
changes in attitude,
results resulted in,
it's being replaced by more.
And Nakia was versions such as grape lane,
grope con was last recorded
as a street name in 15, 61.
You know what I mean?
So all you guys out there used to have
cool names for your stadiums and now you
have a,
I need a job.com arena as opposed
to like war memorial coliseum.
It's been going on forever.
All right.
And you know when they changed it to
grape lane that there was people who still
called it grope, comment and then there
was people like, it's, it's balloon. Okay,
have a little bit of clothes.
Um, go fuck yourself.
What are people doing
down there on grape lane?
You know what that is just the beginning
of like that clean comedy and why you
know, something unique. You need
grape lane for grope Khan to be funny.
You need great Blaine. I'm full of Shit.
It's just fucking annoying me. Like does,
does that mean because
you call it grape lane,
does that mean that there's
any less fucking women down
there getting, you know,
getting their cons groped?
You know,
do you guys know I got, I got an
email from somebody, a, I dunno,
a priest, a pastor. Uh, I
dunno what the fuck it was.
Some person who a holy person
said that they saw me on TV and that
they thought I was absolutely hilarious,
but they wished that I hadn't cursed as
much because it was getting beeped out a
lot.
And then they stumbled across my
podcast and thought the podcast was also
hilarious but just could not get
past the fact of how much I curse.
And um, I don't understand people. I
could see if you have a child there,
but I just don't understand it. Like
adults who just like, uh, you know,
it's like, dude, you're
on the Internet. Okay,
what does nothing I'm saying that's
going to be shocking. Good Lord.
I Dunno. You know what in is he right?
I don't fucking know. You
know what? I don't have class.
Do you know what they normally like about
having class? There's this, there's a,
there's,
there's a lack of honesty to it.
You know what I mean?
The second you put on a pair of a
pair of loafers in a blazer, okay.
And all of a sudden people are looking at
him. He's a gentleman, he's easy client.
And then all of a sudden you start calling
grope con grape lane and that that's
how it begins.
You know,
you start calling it human resources.
That creepy shit. I don't
fucking know. You know,
I like to say fuck, I do.
I like it. It feels good.
You know, nothing. I, you know,
something people out there who are clean,
who don't curse as much. Can
you, can you give me a word, um,
that did that, you
know, when you're angry,
like what word gets it out like that you
can stress and then it ends with that.
You know,
you just,
you just stick the landing like
fucking Mary Lou Retton anyways,
so whatever. My point is that there used
to be a street called [inaudible] Lane,
you know,
back in a more honest time when they
could be head you every five fucking
seconds. Um, you know,
it's one of those deals where you look
back on a time and there's certain things
about it that you liked in other
aspects you didn't, I mean,
I liked the fact that where the whores
wear was called grow current lane,
you know, I mean, shit, you don't
even need a map. You don't need that.
But you know why they had that back then,
they didn't have those little tourist
brochures to let you know that, uh,
where you, what part of
the city you were in? Oh,
it's right there on the corner of uh,
uh,
fucking raped me and grope cunt. Oh yeah,
that's the red light district. Okay,
I got it. Cool. You know, and
then the other side was, uh,
you know, black soles, blacksmith row
and cobbler fucking lane. I don't,
I don't know. You know what? I'm too
stupid to Improv with this right here.
But you know what I'm saying?
Actually, Bill, you know what?
We've known what you've been saying
for the last 15 fucking minutes.
Why don't you get on with the
podcast? All right? It's already 12,
26 out here and I have
something to do at one,
so I got to fucking get
moving along here. Um, oh,
and what I have to start doing is hyping
my shit more towards the front because
I think a lot of people get sick of me
by the end of it. God knows I do. So, uh,
this week I'm going to be at
the Improv in Addison, Texas,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday and Sunday.
And I'm going to the cowboys game,
the Monday night game against
the Carolina Panthers on uh,
on the Monday.
So if you see me stumbling
through the parking lot,
because I will be drinking.
All right,
please offer me a burger or
something like that because a,
I don't know if I'm going to have,
the person I'm going with is going to have
a fucking grill, you know. Um, anyway,
so let's plow ahead here. Uh, and
after next week, the week after,
I'm going to be at the stress factory in
New Jersey and the week after that I'm
going to be in Pittsburgh at the Improv.
Then I have a week off and then
I'm at the uh, Improv in a DC.
So there's no excuse not to see me
on the fucking east coast. All right.
Cause I just got back from Boston. I was
in New York in May. I've been everywhere.
I write. All right, Bill.
Exactly. I know, I'm sorry.
I just been like a real jerk lately.
I've been really like this how I
get when I own, I'm under the gun.
I really shouldn't do like podcasts.
I was under the gun last week. Um,
I dunno. Let's, let's just
plow ahead here. Oh yeah. Okay.
Now people have been asking
me a lot of advice. Um,
my girlfriend had this real weird dream
the other day and I actually interpreted
it to the point where she went, wow,
that was pretty good. And I was like,
you know what? That'd be great.
Should have podcasts listeners,
if you have some sort of,
you have to have one of those dreams.
You just have no idea
what a fucking meant.
And maybe you need somebody insight
into it. Like, here's one for you.
I had a dream the other day I was flying
on an airplane and for some reason I
was faced in the opposite direction,
like I was on a train.
You know those little areas where you
can have like people face each other and
they can discuss the latest styles,
like it's the fucking 18 hundreds. Um,
yeah, I was sitting like that, right?
I was sitting the other way and I was
looking through plexiglass and I was
watching George Carlin doing stand up
and for some reason he was
missing his right hand.
And I was like, Holy Shit, that's
George Karl. And I couldn't believe it.
He's right fucking there.
And what happened to his hand?
And then when we went to get off the
plane, all of a sudden he was really,
really skinny in small and
almost look like an like a woman.
And then I walked around the front,
he had like a beard and he,
and he was missing his fucking hand. And
I, and I, what the hell did I say to him?
I said, well, you know, you, I
think you're really funny, whatever.
And then at with the, I came
out, what the fuck he said to me,
he said something weird back to me and
then walked away and then I got back on
the plane like it was a subway and it
just continued on flying somewhere,
you know? And that's one of those
dreams you just say to somebody in,
they're looking at you
like, uh, uh, I dunno dude.
Maybe you want to fucking may be your
fucking attracted to George Carlin is some
fucked
at all fucking though.
That was just a weird ass fucking dream.
Why is he missing a hand? Why did
he look like a woman? You know,
what's the deal with fucked up dreams if
you have fucked up dream like that one?
Cause I can't make heads
or tails of that one.
Why was I faced in the opposite
direction? Well, build in life.
You feel as though,
you know everybody's just going in this
one direction and you don't agree with
the direction you're going
in the other direction.
That's what you feel and you want to
get to where some of your heroes are.
But there's this invisible
piece of plexiglass that
seems to stop you from going
there.
And a lot of times when you don't do
what everybody else wants you to do,
they say you're evil.
And back in the day when people
used to write with their left hands,
they thought those kids were demonic and
they used to slap their left hand and
make them write with their right hand.
So maybe because your hero was
on the other side of that glass,
he was evil. And that's why
he didn't have a right hand.
See, I can do it. I could somehow
find a fucking through line,
you know?
And then maybe you,
you always want to hook up with
Gloria on a fucking all in the family.
And that's why when you were
walking behind George Carlin,
that's what he looked like. An old Gloria.
All right, let's fucking, let's end this.
Alright, let's plow ahead
here. Um, we actually,
for the first time on my podcast,
I have a follow up email from
somebody that I gave advice to,
to see how shit worked out.
Um,
and of course I can't fucking find it.
Why?
Why do I do this to myself? All right.
As I search for it, I'll tell you,
remember last week when I was telling
you about the guy who had his, uh,
his brother a cock blocked him.
MMM [inaudible]
you know, at the party and he, you
know, he meets a beautiful girl first.
She asked for a piece of cake. He
set up, we'll get you on. He leaves,
he comes back and then his
fucking douchebag, older brother,
he's trying to get her number.
Well, he wrote me back. He said, uh,
well here's what ended up happening.
Um,
that's it. I don't know. Okay.
The next day after meeting that 26 year
old and having my brother's steal her
numbers, she ended up requesting
me on Facebook. Got To
love the Internet. He says,
uh, she then wrote me saying, nice
to meet you. Thanks for the cake.
I wrote back and we made
some conversation, uh,
where I ended with hope to see you around
again. She agreed and said the same,
so fuck it. I asked for a
phone number. Needless to say.
She gave it to me and we played
the phone game for a week.
We made plans to go out to some
club on Saturday. By the way,
I'm not much of a dancer, but if necessary
I can bullshit my way through it. Uh,
my luck could not have been any better.
We got there around 3:00 AM and the
friend she came with ended up leaving
thinking I was taking her home. Whether
they play on that or not, I don't know.
But we got to her house and she a
little tipsy, tells me to come up.
Doesn't ask would you like to come in?
She casually tells me to come in dot.
Getting too crude. I'm proud to
say I fucked the shit out of her.
Funny thing. While I was banging
her, I remember thinking to myself,
wait till I tell bill,
dude,
I really hope this story is true.
All right cause I want the best
for all my 14 podcast listeners.
I hope this happened. Um, had um, anyways,
he said I had to turn my head down
and stop myself from laughing.
Now my brother,
the cup.
Now for those of you who didn't
listen last week or two weeks ago,
whenever the hell I read it, uh,
her brother's a cop. All right.
And he's also a cock block and
Douche bag of identity. Um,
the cop works the night shifts.
Dude,
he's not at copies of fucking security
guard stop it or I was wondering how the
hell he became a police officer at
21 probably works at a video store.
The fucking creep. Anyways, he said we
ended up getting home at the same time,
around 6:00 AM him in his late ships,
late shifts,
security guard brother. He said, uh, I'm
not one to rub shit my brother's face,
but he asked me what I ended
up doing for the night.
So I simply told them I
chilled with that Monica Bitch,
his face said it all with me getting
home at that time he was able to put two
and two together.
I'm not sure whether this counts as a
revenge story or not since I didn't take a
bat to his squad car or anything,
but with the way shit turned out.
I don't think a revenge is necessary.
Also on a different note. Um,
all right.
So we ended up getting it.
Then the rest is about how he has four
dogs and unfortunately he had to put one
down and he told you he or she
gave me good advice. He goes, uh,
you can't believe how much you miss
your dog when it's finally gone.
So make sure you enjoy your dog,
which I did in which I am.
I wrestle my fucking dog. The dog likes
to wrestle. Isn't that right Cleo? Huh?
Good dog. You a good
dog, Huh? Fucking maniac.
You wake me up every morning. Um,
anyways. All right, let's get on to, um,
how bout some youtube videos
for the weekend? Everybody,
let me scroll down here.
I actually have a website that I think
is kind of blowing up on the Internet
right now and I wasn't able to, uh, to
get to it. I think it got too many hits.
These kids started it. It's the name
of the website is people of Walmart.
Just search for that.
And I guess these people go,
they just walk around taking pictures.
Of all the fucking freaks
you see in a Walmart.
And they just thought it was going to
be something that would be funny amongst
them and their friends and somehow
and ended up on funny or die. So, uh,
evidently it's hilarious. Uh,
check that out and for, um,
sports fans because we seem to
have a lot of them on this. Um,
and even if you're,
you're overseas, you can,
you can actually enjoy this one search
bears fan catch it catches kick on
youtube bears fan catches kick and it was
basically from a Monday night football
game about a, I dunno, 20, 24 years ago,
25 years in 1985,
24 years ago,
the bears kick in an extra point.
It's going through the uprights and into
the stands and all of a sudden coming
from like the right hand side of
the TV screen, this guy just jumps,
you know, like a stadium. Like
when you kick an extra point,
it usually goes down and into the alleyway
where the, uh, the players run into.
That's basically what it was. This
guy is like fucking, you know,
a good 20 feet in the air.
He,
and the best part of it is he's
just completely standing up.
I think I've actually talked about this
before in the podcast and he catches the
ball with no fucking concern.
What's fro whatsoever about
his own goddamn safety.
I Dunno who we landed on our what,
but if he did that today in America,
they'd be some sort of al Qaeda nine 11
fucking group of people that would go
after this guy with his
mullet and a z Kaveri cheese.
Like he isn't just some drunk coked up
football fan that can jump to stories
without breaking his fucking ankle.
They treat him like he was some sort
of terrorist and put his face into the
fucking ground. But this is
back in the day. All right,
pre all that bullshit.
They actually showed the replay.
We're talking about what a great
catch it was in Lynn Swann,
the hall of fame fucking wide receiver.
We had one of the best world,
a world series, best Superbowls
ever. Actually interviews the guy.
So check that one out. Check that one out.
Why don't, yeah. Um, all right. That's it.
Now let me get onto the advice.
Like I said,
I've got to blow through it this
week. I apologize. Um, hey bill.
So I was going out with this girl.
She was real cute and real funny and we
had a lot in common. Uh, do, this is a,
this is a fucking weird
story here he goes. Uh,
we had gone out four or five times, so
I thought I was getting sick, you know.
Semi-Serious then one day she called
me and told me we had to cancel,
cancel a dinner. We had planned for later
that week. She had a legitimate reason.
So I was like, just like, I fuck it.
Well, just reschedule. No biggie. Right?
So later in the week I call her and get
her voicemail and leave her a message
asking if she had, uh, she was
free a certain day to have dinner.
She never gets back to me. So I wait
a few more days and I call her again.
I ended up leaving another message.
Fucking nothing. Never calls me back.
At this point, I wait about a week and
call again and leave one more message.
Not a goddamn thing.
What the fuck?
Who does that? Sorry, I
got lost at what the fuck?
Who does that fucking at least call
me? Tell me it's over. Tell me.
I'm lame. Say you have to wash your
hair or your dog ate your love life,
but fucking call.
I talked to my parents and friends and
they have all consoled me and gave me
advice or whatever.
But I needed advice from,
I want you to get some advice
from you. Um, all right, well,
let's be honest. She took
the easy way out. Um,
you know, she obviously didn't want to
see an anymore obviously, and yeah, she,
she took the fucking easy way out and um,
who's getting to a,
breaking up with somebody is one of
the hardest things. The fear of it.
You know,
I saw this thing on intervention one
time where they were talking about drug
addicts and they say basically
they'll spend 20 years avoiding,
you know,
10 days of pain by continuing to medicate
themselves because in their head,
the pain of going through,
getting clean is so fucking huge
that they, that they'll continue,
they'll, they'll, they'll go through
20 years of fucking hell, you know,
and that's what relationships can be like,
where people get into relationships
and they want to break up with someone.
They just don't know how to fucking do
it. And they just thinking, oh my God,
I'm gonna break this person's heart.
They're going to cry.
I want to feel horrible.
Uh, you know, and for guys,
what if they start screaming and
throwing shit and charging me, you know,
with assault,
because when they threw a bookcase at me,
it bounced off my big forehead and
then hit their big toe, you know? Um,
so I know this is gonna
sound fucked up, but his is,
she kind of,
she did you a favor in a weird,
she obviously felt that there wasn't a,
the connection to make it long lasting.
Um,
and I know she took the coward
way out, but at least she, she,
she figured out a way to get out of it
before she fucking rips your heart out of
your chest. I mean, I know it probably
sucked, but it didn't seem like, you know,
you have been gone. You said you're
going to have four or five times.
So I thought it was getting, yeah,
so you went out like fuck, you know,
four or five times,
Dude.
I mean that's some shit you can get
over that at a keg party, you know,
couple of fucking plastic,
16 ounces and you grabbed the fucking
closest Hooters look and chick,
you know, or whatever.
Talk a little bit of Shit.
You know that she did your favorite man.
So I don't know how old
you are with this girl.
Sounds like you guys sound like you're
young and when you're young you really
don't know how to do it. Um, the
best way I found to do it, I mean,
we actually should have like
a fucking class on that.
How to break up with somebody.
First of all,
you got to psych yourself up mentally
to do it and you just have to be like,
all right,
we're going to talk it too and my life
is going to suck from about two to
possibly four 30 or five
and I just have to understand that the
next three hours of my life is going to
suck. You know, it's kind of like if you
had a fight, a kid after school you like,
okay, we're fighting around three. By
the time I remember a buddy of mine,
he used to always get into fights as
well cause I used to be like, dude,
how the fuck do you
fight? Like Dan? He goes,
I just think in an hour I'm going to
be home. I'm going to be in my bed.
Everything's gonna be fine. It's kind of
the same way I look at like, you know,
yeah.
If back in the day when I do a college
gig and they just had me standing in a
fucking hallway with no microphone
and I'm like, all right,
this is going to be absolutely
humiliating. But in an hour from now,
I'll have my check and I'll
be in my fucking, you know,
Buick Skylark rented
from Avis or whatever,
and I'll be fucking drab driving away
from here. And I'd just be a funny story.
Who gives a shit?
So that's kind of what you have to do.
And uh, and you can't leave
any, there's no daylight.
And a great way to stop to start is
just to say that you're not happy.
You know, I'm not happy. Why
Asian? I'm just, I'm not happy.
You know, you're a great person. You can
do, you know, all of that type of stuff.
I feel horrible,
but you know,
it's not working for me and I have
to figure out why. And I just,
this just doesn't feel right in more.
And you got, and you just get that out.
And once you get that out,
then the fucking tears and
all the bullshit comes and
then you just, you fucking,
you just got to stay in
there, take it, you know,
and it's just getting through that
first major fucking day of it.
And then you've got to have other
conversations. Fucking brutal.
It's fucking brutal. So getting
back to this look, you know,
you guys sound like you're young and I
just don't think that she has the mental
ability to be like, yeah,
listen, you know, we've gone
out like four or five times,
I think early,
Nice Guy,
but I just don't feel like it's
going to go anywhere else in bum.
And who's kidding? Who, if she did that,
you'd still be just as fucking pissed.
But it is weird when they just disappear
off the face of the earth like that.
I've, I've had that man. I had the
classic, uh, she's in the shower
in a roommate, sucked at lying
and when she's in the shower,
callback and a half an hour and I
called back and a half an hour, um,
she's repairing her credenza,
callback and 17 minutes and I called
back in 17 minutes. Dude, I called,
I want a fucking moron.
I must've called like eight times and
then they finally stopped answering the
phone. You know? Do you ever have that?
Like you're avoiding somebody call and
in like you think thinking there finally
not going to call and then the phone
rings and you literally get that little
fucking heart attack in your chest.
You're almost scared of the goddamn phone.
Um,
what do,
she did not break up with you and
she did and she did you a favor.
Do cause she could have stuck with you
for another six months and you could have
been walking around telling
all your friends how much
you love her and how great
she is.
And then she dumps you out of fucking
nowhere or bangs one of your friends and
then you got to carry.
You can carry that shit around for eight
years and you know what you do get end
up being stuck going out hurting other
girls who had nothing to fucking do with
that. So in a weird way, consider
yourself lucky you're out of it. You know,
why would you want to waste any more
time with someone who's not NTA anyways?
And you're absolutely right. It was
fucked up. She should have called you,
but she's just not at that
level of maturity and a,
you've got a life to lead so there's
no reason to carry around anymore.
You understand me? So you go out
there, you have a couple of drinks,
you talked some shit to
some broads this weekend.
He put her fucking behind you and
it's football season, you know, uh,
fire up the fucking grill and forget about
her. All right, here we go. Moving on.
Next one. Bill, I watched a couple of
your shows and videos or you stand up.
I really enjoy your work.
Thank you. Uh, but, but the,
but the, all right, um, um,
I've been listening to
podcasts. All right, here we go.
I am a sophomore in and I'm attending a
public school that has a reputation for
being dumb.
Where slutty girls and obnoxious boys
roam freely until the the bell rings.
You know what school I
thought you were describing.
There's a school on the upper west side.
Ah, what the fuck? I think
Paris Hilton went to it.
A CHS knee out.
She knew the name of it.
I think it's called the Dwight school.
And the people said it stood for dumb
white idiots getting high together
cause I guess they were
all like rich kids.
And this kind of sounded like you were
a, you were describing anyways. That's a,
that's an old story.
Anyways.
Not only does my school
have bratty and no annoying,
almost unbelievably ignorant students,
but it is also located in Las Vegas.
Oh that's right. That's how I
knew it wasn't at school. Um,
the hottest slash colas hole in the west.
I am basically a nobody at school and
other people talk to me in school.
They usually describe me as quiet.
I'm the person who when that one person
they talk to all the time doesn't show
up, seems more lost and
more lonely than usual.
I'm very introverted and people
don't really warm up to me,
although I secretly wish they would.
My grades are usually high,
but since I have always been Mousey,
I usually have problems making speeches
and presentations due to not speaking
loudly enough and not
making any eye contact.
I mean it was easily
embarrassed and mistake prone.
And when I'm around my friends, friends,
when I'm around my friends, friends,
teachers and anyone I find intimidating,
uh,
all they do is sit there arguably hoping
I never have to talk to them to summon
up. I'm socially inept. You really
should've said to sum it up, you're,
you're a teenager. This is how
I was. I was socially retarded.
Do you know when I was in,
if I was like right up until like
sophomore year in high school,
if a girl even talked to me,
my face turned beet red.
It's fucking embarrassing to admit,
but it's true.
It was pathetic and I was only funny
around my immediate group of friends.
If I was in a class and it was basically,
you know,
a middle of the pack class and there
was no real popular people in there,
you know, either guys or the
cheerleader girls, then, um,
then I would be myself.
But if any of the popular people,
I just knew my role and
I just shut the fuck up.
So to this day I have a lot of people
who I knew in my past and like,
how the fuck did you end up being a
comedian? Dual use show. Fucking quiet.
Cause that was a fucking
psycho. Um, anyways,
person goes on and says
the only people who, uh,
live in this plane, bug infested house
or my mother on a Chambong of life,
uh, or his life. I mean, I didn't even
see who the, this was guy or girl,
sorry about that.
A bug infested house on my mother and me.
My Dad pays for the major bills,
like the mortgage and rent,
but doesn't live with us
for most of the year. Uh,
he works as a retired
civilian for the navy.
Doing janitorial work on the ship
channel is outside the country.
Yeah.
My mom works currently at a Vietnamese
supermarket and as a cashier, yes,
she is Vietnamese. And like most people
from there that I observed, she cares.
She only cares for Vietnamese and
Chinese people. That's hilarious.
Cause I told that guy he
was being sensitive a few
weeks ago when he was talking
about the fucking,
uh,
that lady at the front desk or the
dentist office being reverse racist.
And I was like, there's
no way that happened. See,
this is why you shouldn't listen to me.
I don't want the fuck
I'm talking about and uh,
I'm going to use your mother as the, the,
the litmus test for everyone in Asia.
I should just shut the
fuck up here anyways.
I can't stand or prejudice
against other racist. The biggest,
most recent mistakes she has made so far,
she's tried to open a business and
it's failed w uh, in less than a year,
which is pretty pathetic. We
ended up being bankrupt, um,
and living without water and electricity
and had to move around a little bit.
After a while we had to make a big change
in lifestyle, which was to move, um,
to Las Vegas. I was furious and upset. Oh,
I guess this person used to live in San
Diego in a neighborhood and always had a
good time out there. And
now you're at the house. Uh,
my two best friends lived in San Diego
and we share so much in common knowing
each other and grade
school. And, uh, thirdly,
my sisters would visit me and take me out
of the House and away from her mother.
Um, so what are you asking me
here? Did I skip something? Oh,
I have a major reason why I
don't want to leave. Okay.
Your mom's taking you out there when we
lived in a nice looking suburb network.
Okay. All my friends are there,
my parents. So I have, okay.
Even though I can't get away
from my current situation a life,
I'm worried about going to college and
living on my own was moving away from
your parents and living
independently hard for you.
Is there anything I should
be warned about? Uh,
no. You just need to relax and realize
that you're a cool person and you're
overthinking shit.
Everything's gonna be fine.
Do you want to learn how
to come out of your shell?
You just work at it the same way you
would fucking learn how to play guitar,
which is to basically do it every day.
You know,
I sucked at guitar three
years ago and now, um, um, um,
getting halfway decent at guitar because
I try to play it every day and the shit
that I still suck at is
a shit I don't work at.
So what I would do if I was you is
just work at coming out of your shell.
You can try it. You know, you go out,
you buy something and try
and make a little chit chat
with the person behind the
register if it's not
fucking automated and a,
and give you a self licensed
to suck in the beginning.
That's the big thing about
improving shit in your life,
I found is to forgive the fact that in
the beginning when you try to talk to
other people, you're a, you're not going
to be good at it at first. And, um,
let me ask you this, have you ever
opened your mouth and said something?
And then an entire room of people turned
around and looked at you and said,
what the fuck? And then they all
beat the shit out of you. I mean,
that was my fear.
That was my fear in high
school that that's what was
gonna happen. You know what?
It never happened. And when I finally
did open my mouth, people are like, hey,
you're funny. You should have been
more like that in high school.
You could have been fucking those
fucking cheerleaders, you know?
So hence I have a lot of regret about
that period in my lifetime because I
wasn't being myself. So, um,
I dunno if you're under age,
you got to go with your mom. So, you know,
you got to go out there just fucking
write it out and you know what it's going
gonna make you a stronger person to go
out there and to be a great exercise and
coming out of your shell to go there,
be the new kid, meet some new people.
And um,
as far as moving out,
the best advice I can give you is a
get a can opener and all that little
innocuous bullshit that you take for
granted in your mother's house. Um,
you know, and then, I dunno, don't,
uh, don't hang around with assholes,
you know,
don't hang out with psychosis and,
but I don't mean psychos like the standing
there with a bloody ax, but you know,
those PE people play like fucking mind
games with you and you feel getting
competitive with you. Those aren't
friends, you know, or you can,
it can happen like one or two times,
but you address it.
And if it continues to happen, dump
them because it's just, you know,
those are the kinds of people that
if you start doing well in life,
they actually resent you.
And uh,
it's kind of like that guy before earlier
that I was talking about with that
woman kind of, you know, saves them
a lot of pain by leaving early.
You can do that with friends yourself.
Does that make any sense? You know,
the second you start seeing
someone's being a Douche,
if your gut is telling you that they
are a Douche and there's no reason to be
around him. But uh, I
hope that helps you out.
I'm kind of rushing through here though
cause I gotta only like eight minutes
left here before I got to
get on. Um, alright bill.
Um, his last advice when
I'm going to read bill,
I've been going out with this girl for,
I love how I'm giving
relationship advice yet.
I've never had a successful relationship,
although I like to think this one's
a little successful, don't you Nia,
who's sneaking around the room you find
you find this relationship successful?
Oh,
define successful.
We have healthy arguments,
don't we?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow. That was hilarious for you went.
Yeah. And then you're like, wait,
that didn't sound like
a good, yeah, we do.
All right. You know what? I was right the
first time. Beat it. Let me finish this.
Oh, look it up. Just one second.
You didn't have to put that over there.
You're just trying to stay in here longer.
Alright, let's plow ahead here. Bill.
I've been going out with this girl for
a little over a year and she's been,
she's beginning to Piss me off.
Ah, Jesus Christ. He, you know,
at this question could be for
about 9,000 people right now.
She complains about not having any money
and never offers to pay when we go out
somewhere. But when she goes out with
their friends to the bar or something,
she spends it like, no
fucking tomorrow. As a man,
I don't mind paying for shit most of
the time, but fucking offered to pay,
you know, but fucking offered to pay
would be a great, would be great sometime,
but fucking offering to pay.
See, it's not always my reading.
Sometimes people don't
write shit correctly,
but fucking offering to pay
would be great sometime. Um,
I don't want to seem like an ass
making the girl pay for Shit,
but give me a fucking break. Times
have changed. Equality is prevailing.
So why don't you throw some
dough like the guys do a,
what should I do to get her to start
spending some money on me or at least
fucking offer without me
making me out to be the Dick?
Basically tell me what you just
told me and take out all the fucks
that seriously do. That's the
secret. You have to, you have to,
and I had to do this because I have a
temper and I say fuck every other word.
I would literally sit down with a
piece of paper and I would write
the,
the two or three points that
I was trying to make and um,
just to make sure that I, I didn't, you
know, that this is what I wanted to say.
And then I would also, and and,
and I would draw out this happened.
I have a how much of a psycho I was.
I had to draw a little
smiley face next to it,
which would remind me not to say it
with my usual angry east coast tone.
All right,
so what you have to tell
her is that basically what
you tell me then a big thing
with women,
you've got to tell her how it makes
you feel when she doesn't offer to pay.
All right? Yet you have to sit
there and listen to her. You know,
complaining about money yet she doesn't
offer to pay and how it makes you feel
when you then see her throwing the money
around with their friends and makes you
feel like what?
Like she's treating.
You see I was gonna say like an ATM.
See,
this is what happens when I don't
write shit down. That's very hostile.
He treated me like a fucking ATM.
What?
I'm not good enough to spend fucking
money on you fucking whore. See,
you can't go that route. You
got it. Oh Jesus Christ. Cleo,
what the fuck are you eating lately?
Just gassing me out.
You know, some, I am convinced with
dogs that there, there is no like, uh,
is no toxins built up in them. They
just don't give a shit. You know,
they got a fucking rip one. They just do.
Um, anyways, that's what you have to do.
You got to tell her how that
makes you feel, you know? Um,
and just, I dunno, you know
what, the more you do it,
you're going to learn how to do it.
And it's like keywords that you can use
with women that makes their ears perk up.
Perk up without getting mad at
you is basically, if you say,
it makes me feel like this and
you use words like, you know,
I just kind of feel like there's a
lack of respect there. I mean that's,
you got to go like this way more,
a sort of mature way and not
because they're more mature.
So get off your high horse is ladies,
you just have to go that way or else
they will fucking turn it around on you.
Okay. The fact that you're
fucking paying for everything,
somehow that point we'll,
you'll somehow be in the wrong.
And um, there's two ways to know you're
winning an argument with the female is,
uh, one, they're trying to pull some
fucking Jujitsu, double reverse,
two point reversal fucking move on you.
And a lot of times last,
their last ditch suicide bomber
fucking mood move is they cry.
All right? And the thing about is a guy,
if you want to win an argument, the woman,
okay?
And I'm not just saying win,
but you really want to make your
point when you know you're right,
because you'll write on this one.
If your version of what's
going on is actually going on,
you're fucking right on this one,
okay?
So what you have to do is not
lose your cool. You cannot get,
don't take the bait and she'll do shit.
She'll bring up shit from your fucking
childhood. She'll bring up mom,
you didn't do the fucking dishes.
She'll do something if you get a dead
to rights, okay? If you, if you don't,
if you do, it all depends on her
personality. If she's a real defensive,
combative person, you really got
to watch out for that breed. Okay.
Those little terrier fucking women,
what you gotta do is just know that she's
going to say all that stuff and that
you, you got to keep your fucking
cool. And once they start, you know,
if they go name calling or something like
that, that's just, that's hostile. They,
they basically that to fucking
word. I can never remember. Um,
God dammit, you know, uh, capitulate,
that's a great word too.
If you use that calmly,
it's basically is when you
just abandon your, the,
the argument and you just start,
you don't reverting to like name calling
or you abandon your argument and they
start agreeing with you or something
like that. I don't fucking know.
It just sounds great to
say it. But anyways, um,
you gotta do you gotta write
down what you want to say,
say it and just say how you feeling.
Take out all the fucks and if she
tries to turn around on you, you know,
by bringing, if she starts bringing
up other shit while you do this,
will you do that? And it don't, don't
allow that. You know what I mean?
And if she wants to to talk about, you
know, are you leave your shoes, you know,
in the middle of the living room, be
like, okay, well before we discuss that,
can we, can we finish discussing this?
You just got to keep steering it back.
It's like fucking law and order.
You've got to cross examine them.
And I'm telling you, watch out for
that cry and bullshit. All right?
Cause that's a latch. Diffs that's
their fucking 60 yard field goal.
Our Hail Mary Pass. When they know
that they're going to fucking,
and I'm telling you,
they're all there like Meryl Streep.
That's why I'm not blown away
by Meryl Streep. Okay. You know,
I have my girlfriends can fucking act
as good as she can. That's bullshit.
She's a great actress. Just
being a Douche. Um, so anyways,
there you go. That's how you do it. All
right? And that's how you win an argument.
If you're right, or at least that's
how you make your point. Okay?
And if they want to revert to name calling
and bring up shit from your childhood,
just don't take the bait and then what's
going to end up happening is they're
just going to be sitting there
feeling like a jerk. And um, you know,
if they're mature enough then they'll
apologize for the name calling and say,
I was actually wrong. I got defenses
but blah, blah blah, blah, blah.
But if there is psycho, they'll
actually try to cry their way out of it.
And I'm just know this,
that when an adult is beyond
the age of, uh, eight,
if you didn't punch them in the
face or call him some horrific name,
there's really no reason to be crying.
So if they are crying, you know,
it's like those fucking
commercials here on the radio,
they give you a free car and you don't
have to give him any money to like
September of 2015. It sounds
like bullshit, doesn't it?
It has to be somehow you're getting
fucked. And that's the same way it is.
Like most of the times when women
are crying, all right out. Okay,
let's get on to some questions
here. Um, oh, by the way,
I gave this guy shit talking about how,
you know,
games weren't invented in England
with the fuck is he talking about?
And here's somebody actually
was trying to tell me, um,
that I was wrong on that one.
Said I would thought ever respond
to your comments about, uh,
what sports did the English and invent.
Um,
I think the English did invent baseball.
It was called rounders,
like in the 17 or 18 hundreds and
it was played mostly by girls.
Not Kidding. Look it up. I
actually looked it up. Um,
and it seems like, yeah, there is a game
called rounders, but that's one of those,
you know,
that's like one of those things like
somebody invents that guitar and then they
take credit for Jimi Hendrix, you
know, I dunno. Maybe I'm them.
I'm exaggerating. Um, I
just don't understand why,
if there is a game like
baseball in England, why you
would play cricket, you know,
and don't they where a bunch of
pads, those big catcher pads, don't,
they wear that shit anyways as plow ahead.
Um,
besides what you mentioned on the podcast,
they also invented,
he wrote Bob Sleigh. Is
that Bob sledding? Um,
tennis, Ping Pong table
tennis, golf in badminton.
While if you want to take credit for those
fucking sissy games, go for badminton.
Really Ping Pong.
I like how you keep inventing games
that then other people dominate golf.
Tiger Woods. Thank you. Ping Pong. China.
You lose that one. Tennis was the last
time saving from England, England,
one to fucking Wimbleton never.
You got to go back to when only white
people were allowed to play and they were
a little fucking a cutoff slacks. No,
actually they work. No, they wore slacks.
That's right.
There were full length pants.
They have wooden rackets that they ate
later use to hit a woman over the head
with the fucking have a
girlfriend. Um, badminton.
Who plays badminton? Members of
your royal family. All right. Um,
I said I wasn't gonna be a jerk,
but I, and I ended up being a jerk.
Let's close out here with the questions.
Uh, Bill, I recently started like,
you know what? It's one oh
three with the fuck am I doing?
I got to get to the questions next week.
I gave out a lot of advice this week. No,
always. No. My disclaimer, I don't
know what the fuck I'm talking about.
All I can do is a judge, you
know, go from my own life here.
How I've handled some shit as the
psycho that I am. All right. Ah, Shit.
That was 53 minutes,
so I didn't even do a short one.
Hope you guys all have a good weekend.
Please come out and check me out, uh,
over the next couple of months
while I get ready for my special,
I mean a Addison at the
Improv this weekend.
I'm at the stress factory in New Jersey
next weekend and the weekend after that,
I'm at the Improv in Pittsburgh.
I'm petting my dog with my foot.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com B, U
R, R for all of my other, uh,
all my other dates are all the
information on the dates that I mentioned.
God bless all of you.
Yes.
Have a great
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible]
Gotcha.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].